ces photographies aurait pu rester dans
des albums de famille et personne sauf
leurs proches n'aurait jamais su où
avait vécu et travaillé ces gens ni de
quoi il rêvait mais tout a changé au
printemps 2020 ce sont des membres du
personnel soignant qui ont sauvé des
vies dans les premiers et donc plus
difficile jour de la pandémie
il n'y avait pas encore de moyens de
protection adéquate pas de zone rouge
dans les hôpitaux pas de distanciation
social chacun d'entre eux dans
différents pays sur différents
continents faisait tout simplement son
travail pour que d'autres puissent vivre
là
voilà comment les médecins urgentistes
de moscou ont célébré le nouvel an en
2020 comme tous leurs collègues du monde
entier
une petite fête des embrassades ys oui
pour la nouvelle année
après 24 heures passées de boue une
petite pause et les nouveaux services de
24 heures qui attendent ils font tous
partie d'un centre moscovite de soins
médicaux d'urgence pouchkov au coeur du
groupe
le pédiatre et réanimateurs michail
lebedev il est en bonne santé et plein
d'énergie dans un mois et demi deux mois
cela changera radicalement plusieurs
médecins de différents centres médicaux
d'urgence pouchkov se retrouveront en
même temps en soins intensifs mirail
lebedev sera l'un d'entre eux il a passé
plus de trente ans a sauvé des enfants
la plus grande partie de sa vie à
iaroslavl
michail mnf et ses collègues ont fondé
la première unité de soins intensifs
pour nouveau-nés de yaroslavl les
médecins locaux n'avaient jamais eu une
telle expérience auparavant jusqu'à 250
petits patients y étaient accueillies
chaque année
on nous appelle escadrons de la mort
comme nous avons commencé à travailler
avec ses enfants
on s'attendait à un taux de mortalité de
100% à être couvert de honte kimchi et à
ceux qui les critiquent et quelqu'un a
pointé du doigt ligne puisqu'elle a pris
à coeur le traitement des enfants des
nouveaux nés ça se passait comme ça
quand nous avions plus de ressources
d'antibiotiques nécessaire entré en jeu
le ventilateur si nécessaire mais si
l'enfant ne pouvait pas se remettre de
lui-même et que nous voulions l'aider si
le niveau de globules rouges diminuait
et si une transfusion sanguine
s'imposait une transfusion notre sens il
a donné beaucoup de son sens et grâce à
son sang chaud disons le comme ça
beaucoup d'enfants se sont remis en 2016
mirail lebedev a déménagé à moscou il a
trouvé un emploi de réanimateurs pour
enfants aux soins médicaux d'urgence
il m'appelait tous les jours comme d'hab
quand il est parti à moscou il
m'appelait tous les jours hélas il n'a
pas appelé
c'était fini
au début on disait que les enfants
étaient immunisés j'ai aussi joué un
rôle important
il a dit qu'il avait été contaminée par
les enfants qui l'avait transporté les
réanimateurs sont vulnérables parce
qu'ils en tube
il a donc été contaminé par un enfant en
lui sauvant la vie
je lui ai parlé la veille de sa mise
sous ventilation claude chêne il était
dans un état critique
sa voix était à peine reconnaissable
chez news
alors je lui ai demandé papa c'est le co
vite que tu as il a dit il semble que
oui c'est très grave il m'a appelé pour
la dernière fois le 16 avril la toute
dernière fois c'était mon anniversaire
il m'a dit maman on pardonne moi et
c'est tout
il n'a même pas fini sa phrase je me
suis rendu compte que son état était
critique
le 18 avril il a appelé pour la dernière
fois il ya dit monfils
on me met sous appareil respiratoire je
te rappellerai dans quelques jours
mihail lebedev a passé huit jours sous
appareil respiratoire
il n'a pu être sauvé il a été enterré
dans un cercueil scellé comme tous ceux
qui sont morts dus qu'aux vives 19 en
conformité avec les règles adoptées
pendant la pandémie
je voulais le voir l'embrasser sur le
front lui faire mes adieux correctement
mais on ne nous a pas laissé faire on
nous a juste donné une photo
mais comment peut-on comprendre à partir
d'une image on y croira jamais je n'ai
pas le sentiment d'avoir enterré mon
père je continue à l'attendre
constamment en fait je rappelle encore
de temps en temps mais le numéro est
hors service
la nuit quand on dort bam dans un rêve
on entend sonner à la porte on ouvre on
voit son père voilà on se réveille on ne
peut pas se rendormir
il sera toujours avec nous peut-être
est-ce la même chose pour tout le monde
ce n'est qu'il sera toujours dans mon
coeur il sera toujours près de moi
breaking temps avant notre arrivée en
amérique mon père avait un business aux
philippines
il achetait et revendait des voitures
quant à ma mère elle était agent
d'assurances
nous sommes cinq au total j'ai deux
soeurs et deux frères
nous sommes donc une grande famille il
avait deux très bons emplois aux
philippines avant notre arrivée en
amérique
c'est un pays tout à fait différent avec
une culture et une langue différente
les parents dû se contenter de ce qu'il
pouvait avoir à l'époque
jameer a commencé à travailler comme
caissière dans une épicerie
après elle est allé suivre une formation
d'infirmière mais elle ne l'a pas
terminée parce qu'elle devait s'occuper
de nous ensuite mon père a également
commencé à travailler dans un hôpital
il transportait des patients tant que
garde malade j'étais de simples
travailleurs de la santé ils ont
travaillé ici pendant 18 ans mind and
mon père c'est mon héros qu'elle sait
que c'est il avait 68 ans il aurait pu
choisir de rester à la maison et prendre
sa retraite
il attendait que ma mère prenne sa
retraite qui est tombé épices et il m'a
dit qu'il ne voulait pas rester à
attendre à la maison s'ils pouvaient
encore travailler était assez fort pour
aller au travail
tout allait bien une semaine avant qu'il
ne tombe malade et walcott nous étions
une famille normale heureuse nous rions
les parents se sont retrouvés en
première ligne c'étaient les premières
personnes à avoir affaire à un patient
avant même le médecin et mon fils je
sais que mon père a contracté ce virus à
l'hôpital car la semaine précédant sa
maladie il avait dit avoir transporté un
patients suspectés d'avoir le qu'ovide
corps est repêché et en amérique quand
on dit suspecté cela signifie qu'ils ont
le coup vide c'est tout simplement qu'on
ne le dit pas à voix haute
quand il nous a dit ce qui s'était passé
j'ai demandé mais n'avait-il pas
vraiment d'autres transporteurs ou aux
soignants plus jeune que toi qui aurait
pu transporter ce patient huntsman gay
non mais mais je connais mon père peut
être que ses collègues ont dit qu'ils ne
voulaient pas le transporter mais mon
père ne disait jamais non à personne
paref des cinq jours plus tard il a
commencé à avoir des symptômes
ma mère travaillait dans une maison de
retraite qui accueille des personnes
âgées n'étaient pas autorisés à porter
un masque à l'époque au mois de mars ce
virus était tout nouveau dont personne
ne savait comment ils évoluent et les
hôpitaux et maisons de retraite voulait
protéger leurs patients le port d'un
masque faisait peur aux gens elles ont
même envoyé un email à l'ensemble de
l'hôpital pour leur dire qu'il n'était
pas autorisé à porter un masque
à moins que ce ne soit requis par
l'hôpital ou donnés par l'hôpital
oui des rois louis ils se sont retrouvés
à l'hôpital à une semaine d'intervalle
là j'étais présent lors de la dernière
conversation que ma mère et mon père ont
eu il a dit tout ira bien
nous irons bien que mm
c'est ma mère a dit oui ça va aller tu
as soon as tu sais la dernière
conversation qu'ils ont eue avant que
mon père fasse un arrêt cardiaque qui se
bat son corps était dans une unité de
soins intensifs à ce moment là j'avais
le coc vide - ici comme nous sommes
allés à l'hôpital j'avais de la fière
n'avions donc pas le droit d'y entrer
mais l'infirmière qui s'occupait d'elle
disait qu'elle pouvait me montrer que
mon père était dans son lit
j'ai ce bel homme dans le pêcheur a
souri c'est une photo de lui s'appelle a
été prise le jour où il est décédé et
pinceaux et mon père s'est battu avec
tout l'a toujours été comme ça il se bat
pour nous pour sa famille un coûte que
coûte
dès le jour où il est parti il avait
déjà subi cinq arrêts cardiaques l'année
elle a aimé cette personne pendant 44
ans je ne sais pas comment on peut aimer
quelqu'un aussi longtemps
les parents étaient inséparables ils
étaient de vrais en séparables il se
suivaient partout à les regarder j'ai
commencé à comprendre ce qu'est l'amour
sont morts à quatre jours d'intervalle
mam voilà ma mère aurait pu décédé le
même jour que mon père en fait
une somme et ils ont dû l'intuber pour
lui sauver la vie
d'accès aux amis des tubes ils l'ont
fait contre sa volonté
la dernière fois que je lui ai parlé
elle m'a dit qu'elle ne voulait pas de
tube
et quand le médecin a dit que s'il
retirait les tubes health en irait tout
de suite
elle cale je n'ai pas pu prendre cette
décision pour elle je n'ai pas pu
afrique et j'avais l'impression que si
je disais d'enlever les tubes je la
tuerais
mais qu'on ne voulais pas la laisser
partir comme ça mon père venait de
mourir ce matin la sauce alors pendant
ces quatre jours elle était un tube et 8
ans nous lui avons demandé dans nos
prières maman si tu veux vraiment partir
avec papa qui va devoir trouver un moyen
parce que nous ne pouvons pas faire ça
tu ne peux pas nous faire prendre cette
décision
oui nous t'aimons et nous voulons que tu
te battes pour nous quand elle est
décédée bien sûr ça nous a fait très mal
et beaucoup de peine mais nous n'étions
pas surpris lorsque comme je les dis
qu'elles sont inséparables nous avions
des liens très étroits et nous n'avons
jamais imaginer quelles seraient les
derniers jours de nos parents ici sur
terre on ne ferait que regarder la
voiture qui les emmènerait au
crématorium ils sont ensemble dans une
seule urne and the beginning
au début quand j'ai reçu lui en eux
j'étais dévastée
haoues vereda vstv un local à wasquehal
est ce que je me faisais du souci pour
eux
mais west elle était malade je me
souviens que je leur disais à tous les
deux et vous ramener à la maison avait
été tout va bien se passer
ks dieu et si bon wigan où nous allons
rentrer à la maison et je vais cuisiner
un homard j'ai cuisiné ray pour nous je
leur disais tous a sonné et donc quand
j'ai ramené lui en à la maison seulement
ni un film nous n'avions pas encore eu
de cérémonie funéraire pour eux parce
qu'ils voulaient reposer aux philippines
c'est pourquoi nous avons décidé de les
ramener à la maison
ils sont inséparables et nous sentons
leur présence et nous savons que
physiquement ils ne sont pas ici mais
ils sont toujours là avec nous avait dit
en mars 2020 l'italie avait le plus
grand nombre de personnes infectées par
le coronavirus au monde puis de
personnes décédées
samarth une job est un médecin
généraliste vénitien ironique qu'une
femme unique et souriante elle souriait
tous les jours au chaud je vais vous
montrer l'image d'une patiente de ma
mère a fait pour moi sur la photo elle
souriait samar avait 62 ans
elle est née en syrie elle a étudié la
médecine à padoue où elle a rencontré
son mari qui était lui aussi médecin
l'italie est devenue leur deuxième
patrie leur enfant raffi et dania ont
suivi leurs traces
c'est une dynastie de médecin il avait
environ 1600 patients
il ya une chose très intéressante à
propos de ma mère et de mon père il
n'avait pas de numéro spécial pour les
patients de pêcher en avait qu'un numéro
il était disponible tous les jours tous
les soirs 24 heures sur 24 avec chaque
jour qui passe est et était de plus en
plus préoccupés par cette maladie c'est
pour jouer travailler était très
difficile à cause du grand nombre de
patients mais elle disait toujours les
maladies ne prennent pas de vacances
quand un patient est malade il faut le
soigner et elle continue à travailler
avec cette malade jouer ici jusqu'à ce
soir l'art en le 6 mars
on est rentré elle ne se sentait pas
très bien comme ça à l'époque on ne
pensait pas que ça pouvait être cette
maladie parce qu'elle n'avait ni fièvre
ni tout elle m'a juste dit je ne peux
pas respirer normalement et si nous
avons fait un scanner et quand nous
avons vu ses poumons
on a compris que c'était locaux vides
les derniers mots qu'elle a dit c'était
s'il te plaît ne dit rien mais patience
parce que je vais certainement revenir
dans quelques jours j'irais bien et
qu'on me dise comment ma mère a
contracté le virus sa chute cherche de
toute évidence cela s'est produit
lorsqu'un patient est venu la voir
convoqué ni masque il faut dire qu'un
masque ne protège pas le médecin à 100%
non maintenant nous utilisons des
masques ffp2 ou au l'edf ou ffp3 bas
mais on a d'abord utilisé deux simples
masques chirurgicaux
symbole masque on nous disait que ça
suffisait les respirateurs sont apparus
plus tard tous les camps ma mère était
déjà à l'hôpital samarth in job à
travailler jusqu'au bout
même lorsqu'elle était déjà hospitalisé
tant qu'elle pouvait encore décrocher
son téléphone
wen shiwen augmenta les allées en soins
intensifs
le médecin m'a donné son téléphone ouais
aïe j'ai vérifié son téléphone et le
dernier message sur what's app avait été
envoyé dix minutes avant qu'elle aille
ou soins intensifs sur youtube c'était
un message à un patient ici et là qu'il
était malade et à lui expliquer quels
médicaments prendre mes marques
aïe je n'ai pas pu faire mes adieux à ma
mère décédée
le 31ème jour à l'hôpital le 9 avril
et s'il est ma mère a été le centième
médecins en italie et le premier médecin
généraliste à venise à mourir du colibri
la première fois que j'ai rencontré mike
c'était au service de noël m'a inquiété
claviériste et au fur et à mesure qu'on
se voyait qu'on se parle et on se
connaissait de mieux en mieux et nos
relations se sont transformés en amour
de la musique nous a vraiment lié bien
ça car nos avions des professions
différentes
je suis couturière et mike était médecin
nous avons chanté ensemble nous avons
créé ensemble et nous avions un grand
rêve en dehors de nos occupations
principales et nous voulions vraiment
joué sur une grande scène indie le 28
avril
il est venu chez mes parents et il m'a
demandé de l'épouser
le mariage était prévu pour le 11 avril
voulions faire une surprise pour nos
invités nous voulions chanter notre
chanson sur scène il m'avait montré la
chanson il ya huit ans je pense lors de
notre première rencontre on avait prévu
de finaliser la chanson ensemble lui
afin que je puisse finir la partie
vocale et on pensait avoir beaucoup de
temps pour la terminer nous avons
reporté le mariage en raison de cette
pandémie
nous avions décidé de reporter au 11
septembre 2021 mike était médecin
généraliste au mondial avec notre peur
est devenue plus sérieuse lorsque le
virus est entré en indonésie richard on
se rendait compte que en tant que
médecin remake était obligé d'avoir
affaire au virus directement
il n'ya comme mon mari mike et sa petite
soeur son médecin défaite de ma vie je
savais à quoi nous devrions faire face
font leurs devoirs professionnels ainsi
qu ils font leurs devoirs devant le
seigneur
cela m'a toujours donné la force et la
conviction qu'il travaillait pour une
bonne cause
malesza à l'époque mike ne portait qu'un
masque des lunettes de protection et des
gants puisqu'au début de l'épidémie ne
coronavirus équipements de protection
individuelle n'était pas diffusée aussi
largement de nombreux travailleurs de la
santé n'étaient pas entièrement équipée
et comprime eyes on me signale le 17
mars 2020 mike a dit qu'elle se sentait
un peu plus mal mais il disait que ce
n'était rien de grave et il a continué
son travail de médecin rial iranien
le 9 avril son état s'est soudainement
grave et après s'être rendu à l'hôpital
les résultats du test se sont confirmés
positifs
aujourd'hui c'est le huitième jour de
mon traitement je suis devenu d'une des
victimes du que 20,19 certain que je
suis honorée et fière d'être médecin
soit robert landry cet épisode de
pouvoir servir les patients d'aidé de
nombreuses personnes je souhaite que
tous mes amis réussissent et n'oubliez
pas d'utiliser tout l'équipement de
protection individuelle
le jour où on avait initialement prévu
le mariage ils étaient en isolement et
en tant que maire j'ai pleuré parce
qu'il aurait dû se marier ce jour là au
lieu de cela ils étaient à l'hôpital
il nous passer des appels vidéo ou sur
what's app
il nous disait quand je serais sorti de
l'hôpital et que je serai en bonne santé
je te serrer dans mes bras maman son
mobile
il faisait tout le temps les tests le 22
avril les résultats ont été négatifs et
on l'a laissé entrer chez lui
suite à ces résultats et l'a dit il est
revenu 22 avril et le 23 avril à la
loupe
il s'est de nouveau senti très mal nos
hôpitaux
je me rappelle l'avoir conduit au choix
intensifs a qu'un pas
la dernière fois que je veux mais avec
son visage il a dit ses derniers mots il
a dit je t'aime tellement
mais elle prend soin de maman de papa de
peaches oui beatty et puis il m'a dit
mon amour je suis moi-même un art mineur
je comprends ce qu'ils n'arrivent
et à ce moment là je senti à quel point
il se sentait mal
je devais me préparer à perdre la
personne que j'aimais le plus souvent
beaucoup de gens considéraient mec comme
un bon médecin
avant sa mort beaucoup de gens le
considérer comme un bon médecin il
traitait toujours les gens avec le
sourire sinon tant de gens l'aimaient
banias voilà ce que disait des gens que
nous ne connaissions même pas il déplore
aussi la perte de mike d'un bon médecin
d'un médecin compatissant très attentifs
ils leur transmettaient toujours toutes
ces émotions
il voulait aider il était comme ça
michael seulement quelques personnes ont
pu assister aux derniers adieux de maïs
il faisait beaucoup de petites choses
pour me faire rire il me tenait la main
dans la voiture il est même embrassé
m'embrasser sur le front est ce qu'il me
disait qu'il m'aimait il m'a écrit une
chanson j'ai fait un mic la promesse de
terminer cette chanson i'm your new moon
aa janeiro